die nächste stadt verloren an russland
die ukrainische armee hat sich aus lyss
chance im osten des landes zurückgezogen
lang und heftig wurde die stadt umkämpft
dennoch bewege sich die ukrainische
armee vorwärts sowohl im gebiet charkiw
im osten als auch in gebieten im süden
und auf dem schwarzen meer das sagte
präsident ziel entgegen seiner
nächtlichen ansprache und er kündigte an
denselben fortschritt den werde es auch
im hart umkämpften donners geben ich
werde jetzt mit paul ronzheimer in der
ukraine über die aktuelle situation
guten morgen paul von welcher bedeutung
ist der verlust von des teams
es ist jetzt keine zentrale stadt über
die ganze welt gesprochen hat patricia
weil es ist ein symbol dafür dass
russland langsam aber sicher vorankommen
wir waren noch vor einer woche in dieser
stadt wurden dort auf dem weg hinaus
beschossen haben die zerstörung gesehen
dass russland jetzt vorfinden wird ist
eine fast komplett zerstörte stadt mit
artillerie ist man da acht wochen drauf
gegangen hat alles versucht zu
bombardieren was möglich war was die
ansprache von sinnen ski angeht da
glaube ich doch ist er etwas zu
optimistisch momentan all das was ich
höre auch von ministern von beratern ist
eines wir haben weiterhin nicht genügend
waffen um uns im osten so zu werden dass
russland nicht weiter vorankommt und uns
fehlt es vor allem auch an munition
sprichst sehen wir auch bilder
weißrussland hat jetzt auch noch mal
eine drohung und auch seine solidarität
gegenüber russland und eine drohung
gegenüber dem westen ausgesprochen wie
schätzt du das seien
drohungen aus belarus gibt es und gab es
immer wieder schon seit beginn des
krieges die spekulationen ob red arrows
möglicherweise hier in den krieg
eintreten könnte die sind vorhanden auch
in kiel wird man da durchaus nervös denn
wenn boulahrouz kommen sollte wenn
tatsächlich bodentruppen kommen sollten
oder ja man in diese richtung marschiert
dann wäre klar wo ich gerade stehe
wieder auch einen angriffspunkt und das
ist das was dann am ende natürlich
gefährlich wäre für die ukraine momentan
aber kann man sagen glaubt man nicht
dass lukaschenko den nächsten tagen
nächsten wochen hier in den krieg
eintritt
gleichzeitig verkündete man eher von
seiten der ukraine es werden hunderte
milliarden euro für den wiederaufbau
benötigt man fragt sich ist das jetzt
schon der zeitpunkt um über den
wiederaufbau zu sprechen war ja auch
thema bei g7 ist es nicht ein bisschen
verfrüht und bewirbt wer soll dass am
ende alles bezahlen
man kann was eigentlich gar nicht früh
genug darüber sprechen über diesen
wiederaufbau patricia wenn ich hier kiew
anschaue dann ist zwar im zentrum das
meiste heilige blieben aber wir kennen
die bilder aus rp in butter da bräuchte
es trinkt bereits jetzt finanzielle
mittel die größere frage die natürlich
überall besteht ist sind diese städte
die einmal bombardiert wurden und dann
wo es dann abgezogen hat sind die jetzt
irgendwie sicher und da ist die antwort
nein russland könnte jederzeit wieder
auch kiew angreifen man tut das ja auch
ja alle paar wochen momentan zumindest
mit raketen auch andere große städte
werden angegriffen allerdings kann es ja
nicht jahre so sein dass städte so
aussehen wie er den pin zb und dort kein
wiederaufbau stattfindet damit muss man
dann schon irgendwann anfangen sagt paul
ronzheimer uns zugeschaltet aus kiew
vielen dank für den informationen